Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios has been talking about Nova
making an appearance in the MCU for some
time now and it seems like they may have
just dropped a Nova Easter Egg right in
front of our eyes and spider-man far
from home what's up everyone it's Warren
and don't worry I'm not going to be
spoiling anything about spider-man far
from home if you have not seen it yet
the easter egg has nothing to do with
the plot of the movie but if you have
seen the movie you may have spotted it
and even if you haven't seen the movie
you may have heard of it because many
people are talking about it right now so
let's go ahead and break down this Nova
Easter Egg quick heads up if you would
like a chance to win a Captain America
shield an Iron Man helmet and Infinity
Gauntlet or another Marvel Legends item
be sure to subscribe to my channel to
enter my giveaway I'm picking three new
winners at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers so again in this
video I will not give away anything
about spider-man far from home so if you
haven't seen it don't worry this Easter
Egg is found when Peter is on the plane
leaving New York to go on his vacation
when Peter looks at the TV in front of
him for the in-flight entertainment you
can see a number of very interesting
documentaries there's one about the snap
that shows Spano says gauntlet one about
finding Wakanda another about hunting
Hydra and then you have one that says
Nova the documentary that has Nova on it
also says einstein-rosen bridges with
dr. Erik Selvig and it has dr. Selvig on
the cover now it's important to note
that Nova is an actual show about
science and speculation that appears on
PBS and it seems like for this
particular episode of Nova they are
talking about einstein-rosen bridges so
they have brought on dr. Erik Selvig as
a guest but this is a very peculiar
thing to put in this in-flight
entertainment especially when you put it
besides the snap finding Wakanda and
hunting Hydra and you have to remember
Marvel does everything intentionally
there are so many different Easter eggs
and all of the movies that they do
nothing is ever done by accident which
means there has to be a purpose for
putting Nova in the in-flight
entertainment because if you think about
it the other three movies are all fake
they only exist in the MCU so why would
you throw in a TV series that exists in
the real world if you didn't want to
specifically use its name because there
are plenty of other scientific TV shows
that they could have put there but they
specifically
to use Nova and if you think about what
we know about phase four we know that
there is going to be a guardians of the
galaxy volume three happening very soon
and there are numerous amounts of
reports rumors leaks that say we are
going to be seen the introduction of
Nova in guardians of the galaxy volume 3
which will set up his solo film and if
you tie this together with what Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
has said about Nova recently it all
makes perfect sense in an interview that
wasn't too long ago Kevin Feige was
talking about introducing Nova into the
MCU when talking with comicbook.com
about what new characters could be
entering the MCU Kevin Feige said if we
have a big board with a bunch of
characters that have more immediate
potential Nova is on that board because
of the connection to the guardians
universe because there are more than one
examples to pull from in the comics that
are interesting and you're absolutely
right he was in the earliest drafts of
guardians of the galaxy
so Kevin Feige has said previously that
Nova is a character that has immediate
potential to enter the MCU and Nova was
in the earliest drafts of guardians of
the galaxy and we know that Nova was
supposed to be in Avengers infinity war
the directors and riders after avengers
endgame came out and said that there was
originally a scene with Nova and Thanos
fighting ons and are so Marvel is really
trying to introduce Nova into the MCU
they're just waiting for the perfect
opportunity but it seems like we could
be getting very close Marvel has been
trying many times and now we have a nova
Easter Egg Nova could be introduced as
early on as in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 which would go on to introduce his
solo film later on down the road in
phase 4 so it seems like Nova entering
the MCU is pretty imminent and will be
seen it happened very soon be sure to
comment down below and let me know your
thoughts about this nova easter egg and
spider-man far from home also be sure to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like the video and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof